when you get the right feature in the
right demographic like i tell people
this
my ultimate goal and no shade to dizzy
or jiren was to work with hopson right
so i wasn't necessarily trying to get a
dizzy feature or a german feature i was
trying to get a hopson feature so when i
inquired about hobson they was like he's
got a show coming i saw he was coming to
arizona i'm like i want to get a feature
with him and shoot a video dame hit me
back and was like nah
hopson doesn't really do features but i
got dizzy wright and jaren benton and
these this is dizzy's price and so i did
the song with dizzy for
500
is what he what he charged for the
feature and then they had just signed
jiren so they put him on the song for
free they put him on their channel now
obviously this isn't the typical way it
would go but
ideally if you're if you want to work
with a team or a camp or anything like
it's as simple as working with a
photographer that works with these
people you want the person you want to
work with to see your stuff so if you
get in the right teams in the right
camps that make sense for your audience
it's a cosign and it's something that
can grow into something way more so that
500 feature turned into
three more songs with dizzy two tours
with dizzy a tour with hopson
multiple songs with jaren benton like
uh
then weed sponsorships and i don't even
smoke like that 500 has made me way over
half a million wow based off of just
reaching out and getting that right
building the relationship and i also i
always tell this to people i'm like yo
if you're gonna do a feature with
someone make sure that their fans are
super engaged yeah because then you can
kind of like if you're dope you kind of
like steal not steal you know but you
can do you can steal you can kind of
purge some of their fan base to be your
fans that's how i felt about everything
that i did anytime i talk to an artist i
say it's all about platforms what
platform can you get on if i have a song
about weed then how many weed blogs can
i get on how many weed instagrams can i
get on how many weed tick tock pages can
i get on and that was kind of the mode
with everything so an artist another
artist is another platform their
platform is for you and so how can you
capitalize on that to the most so like
when i do something with somebody it's
like okay well let's do like a giveaway
like let's do something to where like
your fans damn near have to follow me
and my fans have to follow you or advice
you know whatever i can do to where it's
like we're both going to get the most
out of this opportunity and it's going
to be beneficial um so anytime somebody
gets a feature it's yet and then build
on that like don't work with somebody
who's not willing to post your [ __ ] yeah
you want to make sure that they're going
to like actually promote you and then
also like keep following up on that
relationship don't just do the song and
then just and be out thank you man yeah
yeah peace yeah